Super Bowl we got all kinds of issues
new studio bro new studio I'm a little
fired up I'm on the way here you've been
driving on our way here you hear
something on the radio that gets you
fired up amazon apparently wants its
employees to wear wrist bands so they
can track their even their how their
hands move why because they want to bro
caning it's got it's a risk man instead
of scanning with the scanner now the
wristband will just automatically do it
and here's the here's the thing only
when they're at work
only well only when they're at work but
here's the thing when you're working and
if they feel like you're like it has a
patent they got the patent for this okay
if you are if your hands aren't where
they should be so in other words
technically you're not only if they're
not really not in where the if they're
not where the boxes it'll give you a
nudge look at you know yep yep swear to
God
no what were they they can tell exactly
what your hands have been doing through
the whole workday so there's no idle
time man so they would come like uh yeah
Brian when you talk to you so we see
you're on the computer about 10 minutes
total during the day and then throughout
the day several times you're making a
jerking motion your hands on be
concentrated and oh mister right hand
your lower extremity huh
and we're not sure what you're drawn
right well I will Amazon let me look at
you
I'm busting nuts I'm busting nuts under
my dashboard under my desk I don't know
I don't agree with that at all no at all
it's like there's nobody getting crazy
annoying well they just bought the
patent yeah I know well I guess he
simply sensibly it saves time right
because when you don't know where a box
is it'll nudge you in the direction
where the box is just just you know what
just go to all robots I'm gonna do that
just go to robots what does that [ __ ]
robot we're gonna get do it we're gonna
mesh with machines I people talk about
robots but I think we're gonna start
meshing I'm wearing robot did you see
our I didn't post it a friend of mine
sent me the link I sent it to Rogen
for the CES I think yeah the CES
convention SAS sapphires had read yes
oh yeah I was interview seeing robot
stripper seen it and have you seen at
the
the dolt video awards or the convention
they have actually if you know those
things get problems but I've been asked
I see that as a regular man asked to MC
shark eyes doll smile got asked to
participate in one of those things as a
Godzilla suit anyways he turned it down
so yeah I can't have my brother do now I
can't be in a porno absolute justice
Godzilla mouth with your fat dick we'd
all realized we have a friend who when
he was younger was in a porn I won't say
who but I'll tell you later
well what he did was he was in a porn
back when he was younger and he wore
sunglasses and a bandana oh yeah because
we have no idea who that is no he knew
and got involved I was like your daddy
cuz yeah that's a nightmare
yeah can you imagine doing that so you
know you know Amazon right now it's down
to like five cities where they relocated
we're gonna put up their new
headquarters so in those five cities
Real Estate's gonna skyrocket its Denver
I think Boston Wow Philadelphia yeah
I forget the other ones I first you
don't know would like to advocate I
think it's gonna be Denver because Stan
Kroenke who owns a bunch of property
like Elitch is over there Six Flags he
saved that and he's gonna sell it to
them they think he has some sort of
insider info because he's hold on that
to sell to Amazon but the Denver Mar
could go already you know now with weed
though now that Jeff Sessions said that
weed that that Attorney General's and
states can go after weed dispensaries
like it's illegal and they should go
after them and a lot of the Attorney
General's a lot of just like like State
Justice Department's are like we're not
gonna do that no yeah I already know
it's do however the problem is it's
really hard for like if you have you
want to expand with your pop business
you need investment you can't get it
from banks right because they're federal
and you can't keep your money in federal
banks no so it's just a whole easy ways
to go about it
wink wink where were you DC boys in DC
we sold all the tickets Thank You DC for
coming out what a blast little too cold
I'll be honest with you sometimes things
are too cold when it hurts my base whose
area was colder cuz I was Denver Satan
Lewis DC's pretty cold no DC was CDC was
actually more like 28 23 degrees not the
same yeah that sucks yeah there was
still in my brother I don't I don't know
I mean he gets paid well
job refused to turn the heat on in the
house now he decide Costa de video I was
like because I was that the comedy works
first I'm doing stand-up the solo down
the downtown area and they give you a
place to stay
and usually when clubs give you play
States you may not you know it's not
that great the Comedy Works ones amazing
it was like the real world house it was
sick was that's a hell of a condo it's
amazing it looks it looks like R&R today
we're a blank check
like some kid built it yeah but I was
like you know what I'm in town I'll stay
with my brother I never see you know all
the family and friends stay with him and
it was I don't know 18 degrees out and
he refused her on the heat so I slept in
jacket sweat socks yeah those are dogs
you have those filthy animals huh those
giant mops I'm basically giant mops with
eyes it's like take a mop and just never
wash it but have a mop a giant mop and
just have it run around and dirt and
everything else and then just have it
get real affectionate without with eyes
it's very it's a hundred fifty pounds
yeah huge Adam Deborah was cool saw her
boy Cody everyone's doing great man
great yeah I had this guy he died
co-feature so there's an MC
then there's your B feature and there's
a feature than the headliner right and I
just got this guy who I basically grew
up with name's JJ Billingsley I'm it's
just a Chan I'm big brown breakdown I
played football with them usually
Colorado but he was the funniest guy in
the limey by the funniest [ __ ] guy
and someone reached out to me was like
he's doing stand-up night you know it
for like three or four years I'm like
really again but he can't get any spots
so I so I got ahold of his number
through a friend of a friend
I went JJ coming to town sold out shows
you down to do you know five or six
minutes he's like dude this is the break
I need blah blah and I was super nervous
for him because you know the comedy
scene in Denver is pretty good yeah the
the emcee you're stalking on the
greatest clubs period yes love to come
yes in a sold-out show so packed room
yeah so then great is that cuz it's a
low ceiling that's a real comedy room
yes just real quick though because if
you see how dense it is that that that
laughter rolls that is a slow
walks around like ooh shakes is
ridiculous and it's handled well well at
20 amazing so I tell JD ready to do this
he's like Yemen and I'm nervous for him
like oh god man and they sent me he sent
me someone's standing before my still
this goes and he crushed it man because
but because the guy who was behind him
the the a feature was won a bunch of
awards he just moved there from Chicago
he went funny stand-up and Chicago funny
stand-up and so he was hard to follow
know well JJ went before him I like this
guy did you know 20 minutes and Tiki
Tiki Tiki could get ya killed the crowd
yeah yeah JJ was just his dad was there
yeah I introduced him cuz I'm like dude
hope you get more spots in the the guy
who's emcee puts on shows that God get
you spots man I was just proud of them
that's really I know he did great man
it's really cool now went from freezing
Denver with my brother who's too cheap
to put on heat to st. Louis and all
smile came to came to see Louis yeah Kim
st. Louis and how are those crowds you
know what so st. Louis gets a bad rap
like every comic I thought you goes dude
st. Louis awful comedy town don't go to
st. Louis don't in st. Louis and you
know we sold a bunch take it and like I
got a guy yeah check it out see the
crowds and I just think maybe they're
not used to kind of like there's a lot
of talking there's a lot of cell phones
they're just trying to it's a newer club
in the helium problem at the at the
audience is in st. Louis it was more of
the town itself that I mean I love see
they love mark and I love their I love
the helium brand but the crowd was great
the town itself is for me I'm a snob and
I yeah oh but you know we stayed right
by that Washington University Washington
of st. Louis that place so accelerate it
looks like Harry Potter school enormous
it's one of the harshest schools getting
through in the nation
private school brilliant stuff but Jay
and I were like alright we're both off
our diets will start diets Monday he was
on paleo we went nuts Weiss dude we went
to this place called PI I didn't know
jokes on diet is he doing that paleo
thing
he's doing paleo think you can do it him
and his wife been doing for a while but
I auntie he's you know the pie the side
like 3.14 that's that pie yeah and we
went into this restaurant and we sit
down I'm getting hints weird cuz I'm
getting like you where I question like I
asked him what's your favorite what the
ingredients use all the stuff Jay say
come on man and I'm like what do you
recommend and she goes what he got I'm
like what who got and I look over my
shoulder and there's a big picture of
Obama their pizzas so good when Obama
was the president he would fly them in
to cook their pizza for him Wow
yeah what's he get and they told me I'm
getting that yeah you damn right this
Beatson was might be the best beats I've
ever had
now hold on it was so goddamn it's well
it's not better exactly the Frankie it
was deep-dish bro okay you're right
mouthing wrong Jersey and you had you
said to me you had great pizza that's
different though that was thin like New
York style
this is deep-dish this was deep dish and
so good bro Barack Obama's from Chicago
he goes Nashik ah go I'm gonna flying
the people from pie in st. Louis to cook
my pizzas she was the chef might be from
Chicago and it was ridiculous oh my god
it was so nice well what kind of pizza
did you get was deep dish and get my
hand on my pants
I know it's deep-dish and then it had
like the marinara sauce on top and the
settings and then the she's underneath
the cheese and like the pepperoni
underneath cats kind of rock it was
delicious
Jesus and then the next and then a bunch
of fans you know when we do the
meet-and-greet they go you gotta go to I
think it's called Bertos or some a
juggler throws barbecue oh my god like
barbecue barbecue so then we go this
Bertos now before we go to Bertos see
what it is change to give st. Louis
barbecue its ranked it's on zag it's
like number one barbecue place in
America or some [ __ ] like that so Jay
you know Jay likes the sightseeing [ __ ]
I don't it's all the same to me he want
to see like the arch which I refuse to
go to and then he's like oh they have
grown-ups like museum play museum like I
don't go now he's like knowing everyone
said it's great even the cop the opener
was like you guys should go there we
take an uber there we walked in this
place and it is basically a Chuckie
Cheese for kids not adults at all I have
a hood on in glasses
Jay has his glasses on Jay doesn't see
that you have to pay for you can get a
man we try to walk in I see security
Naja go like we're to pedophiles and
they grabbed jaylen whoa what are you
guys trying to do I'm like what we're
not I'm sorry what is this he goes this
is a Children's Museum Mikey where are
you two trying to go I like the
gentleman your [ __ ] he does goddamnit
the reviews were good on it
you're weird man we'd like to to
pedophiles right now I've that's the
worst at Children's Museum I'm not gonna
have the [ __ ] do
oh it's called Bogaerts like yeah right
there actually I think our son actually
ate there at plays st. Louis so we got
there yeah Ange and I go uh what's good
here
and she goes well we're known for our
ribs don't put sauce on because we put
like this peach glaze on them you can
put some sauce and she goes I'm sorry we
only have one rack laughed and and
there's all huge line performance
because we don't bring it back when it
sells out sells out I said I'll take the
full round you eat ribs
I heard the guy behind me go
[ __ ] really oh I got that full
rack now when you eat the rack is that a
pig rack or is that a beef rack pig rib
sir okay now I can tell them scream pig
and beef ribs the beef ribs are too big
Reza pigs are tiny well they can't think
of another slaughter a baby pig no no I
I had I went to a restaurant called De
La Salle yeah dance out dumb in [ __ ] you
know DC and this is what I get sold on
when the waiter will say something like
well I would recommend the pork chop
because it's it's a corn-fed and they're
they're allowed to forage and it's a
corn-fed and you're like what they'll
sell I on that I know I go a corn-fed I
don't know what that means but that's
how I'm in cuz and they go it gives the
meat a really beautiful sweet and my
mouth is watering about this decides the
beans and the in the goddamn well I'm
for me a potato salad yeah pork might
not mind it pork is maybe my favorite
do not mean I like the ribs outside that
I don't dig it I don't know a huge pork
guy I do pig farmers came to my show and
it was like brothers these brothers they
offer you pigs they'd a wet day gave me
where they purvey the the restaurants
that they sell their pork to and how
they raise their pork and I was like
damn our Pig smartness [ __ ] yeah
okay and and so he went through the
whole thing and I was like I had a pork
weekend my mouth is watering so bad that
was so goddamn delicious and in
styrofoam cups but you don't care no
that's the way to eat I want it that's a
way to eat ribs and when I asked the
lady I get one and I said what else what
are you known here for bath shoes will
our R is but can I recommend the turkey
and the pastrami when I had both those
getting now [ __ ] yeah you know what
matter of fact i'ma stop taking
recommendations for me I was gonna help
us at hi Turkey when you got ribs Turkey
push em yeah it's wrong with you we're
not what do you the worst speller every
time getting boring bird I told you I
ate a wild turkey and it tastes exactly
like shitty Turkey they all get the [ __ ]
out of here with your boring bird your
fat bird it's like you know what turkeys
are made to eat I get it like when Steve
Rinella we were I guess like we're
hunting and he goes look you can't move
and you got to wear a face mask because
they're gonna see you and it goes
because here's the thing about Turkey's
I was like I was waiting for something I
was at what and he goes everything wants
to kill a turkey
turkeys are dying all the time die die
die like they're put on their stress
some [ __ ] animals yes somewhere on
the earth to be eaten only that's why
when a deer drinks it drinks and looks
up drinks it looks up all the time bring
up that bring up that [ __ ] Impala
being eaten by a crocodile and no look
at this so imposed to the video someone
posted a video it said oh four five and
it shows these like little dears up
gazelle trying to cross the river this
is what this is it any they're going
Coosh Coosh Coosh like there's one where
this where this it's it's on you can you
be better off on Instagram chin it's
called it's the crazy animal [ __ ] that
everyone follows it's it's this crazy
metal yes go to that one it goes one
four five major and park yeah he's ten
years younger than me he also has 400
more fights than you know I mean he's a
legend but but that that's his skin gets
thick when you get hit um a lot of scar
tissue man yeah boy died only elbows and
[ __ ] yeah to go to nature is metal for
me the one that says Oh for fun
oh they're the top right yeah I think
that's it so watch how fast oh no no
there's another one oh watch this be
well you watch how fast that croc swims
yeah
watch this for me though look at them I
will get through don't worry I got on
then watch this dumb one that's like God
I think we can do it let's do it boys
watch this I'm going for us you guys
other side wrong oh dude it's just our
feast loose rocks douche how about these
two go all right you pansies we'll see
you guys on the other side and by the
way if it was really due to Jim oh no
jeez oh no there's another one where
this this Impala is crossing and you see
how fast the crocodile is he looks like
a speedboat dudes like how about how
about soin it's not the imposed - video
went looking for a tasty treat and it's
a giant water buffalo staying there with
these fat black nuts ain't bulldogging
out the back yeah and this hyena is
slowly crawls up and grabs his nuts and
rip ah
well one of the worst things I saw all
Sun so that's how my Sunday morning
start off at 3:30 in the morning yeah my
father my father who in his old age does
nothing but watch all kinds of videos
are knocking on [ __ ] polar bears and
big cats and everything else was telling
me that and he said it really casually
he goes well when they when they take
down the water buffalo they eat the
testicles and then they begin to eat the
animal from the the anus and I was like
don't just say that without like having
a cringe on your face don't just say it
like that's normally happens yeah
because that just [ __ ] my whole day up
no I'm tired this morning said it's it's
sensitive material Mike doesn't scare me
and it says these are a bit of a
delicacy or a treat and I look I'm like
what is I'm like yo some fat ass nuts on
that Buffalo and then this little hyenas
like they are fat huge you can't there's
nuts
oh you can't protect your Buffalo I
gotta see it now I don't know where it's
right I gotta see it I'll look it up
what type in water buffalo uses nothing
because this is what happens water
buffalos lose their nuts if you're a
water buffalo you're gonna lose your
nuts when they take it out and you
they're pretty testosterone and then you
get fat oh there it is
well leave them fat leave him fat nuts
hanging out the back he's Bulldog he's
nuts at the back like that one distracts
and this one goes yeah oh and they have
the strongest bite in the world oh
that's gotta be let's turn around and
[ __ ] stomp that thing but when
someone clear go back let me get him off
because you see him no I'm saying go
back to with the go to that yeah I go
that bottom that one right the second
one in yeah get off my nuts bro can you
just run on him and then house is hiding
or not like how do you not hear this
white bean is attacked and killed I
thought they waited oh hell no son
especially when you got them nuts like
that I mean there's a mother it's sucks
dude oh then they eat them pass out wife
eats life gonna kill this well there go
your balls game over to them can't
protect your nuts I might be better in
Bertos BBQ um and I would practice
there's a way to push your balls into
your body you know not if you're if
you're a but if you're a sound right
that's what you do how many fighters
that ever did that
oh no that's fake Brian that's fake yeah
that's all I've heard though that people
can happen there my age
no one's training that god that poor
water buffalo why did his nuts get him I
don't know dude it's a disaster it's a
fight you're so terrible disaster like
when we when we when we looked up those
birds I was thinking I like how brutal
is nature do you know who has the
biggest nuts in the animal kingdom
kingdom in the ape Kingdom just of the
great apes including us
chimpanzee that's right she bones sure
mother you know where the second one's
us but the chimpanzee has way bigger
nuts but a smaller [ __ ] gorilla he had
back bar the girls doesn't yeah we have
the biggest dick
longest and thickest dick out out of the
the primates primates yeah that's not
saying much though now and also it's a
little skewed cuz the black guys wieners
that guys wieners
yeah man obviously they're bigger in
general so you know the scales can be
like this white guys are like in the
middle
they say Greek guys have Greek guys and
Native Americans have dicks the big you
know I told you Jamie was talking with
Wars this this this nurse who's a works
in Neurology and she was in her late 30s
and seen 10,000 dicks and Jimmy goes who
has and she goes the biggest dicks mmm
great brakes 100% Greeks if your last
name ends in O us you got the biggest
dick and that's a fact I've seen all
dicks I've seen all the black guys dicks
no bike ever go to that doctor she's not
they're not checking with that doctor
yeah Greek guys are other way about the
hell I wonder we've looked it up before
the Hawaiians depends you might be
surprised
do you think I think you would be I
don't know although there are certain
I'm not saying I've ever been on those
sites but black calm black calm they are
they'll make you cry Jews guys Aniki
I've had people there the meet and
greets come up me and they'll just tell
you like my husband you know you guys
are big dick Bennett's my husband just
loves well when he watches porno when a
black guy goes hard on a white lady look
what he cool there's that I know it's
hard think you you want even Majan what
those guys carry like no I've seen it
I've looked up myself Rogan usually
Rogan used to do a bit he did some
research on interracial porn black on
white women black men and white women is
I guess the most popular the most racist
parts of the country yeah yeah that's
really interesting
he's just really funny a bit about it
but how about this new studio man it's
probably it's so vast why is it why do I
feel weird it's right twice the size of
our old one right chin definitely twice
the size now did you spend 48 hours
straight putting this together just a
lot of work maybe longer than 48 hours
maybe no the zebra had dope yeah and
you're so nice about I was pretty nice
Texas very back and white
very black-and-white yeah I broke this
thing I'm like alright well that was a
cheap man you know and he's like well
sorry like and chin is so consistent and
now we have the space and the
capabilities we're gonna get going here
to where we'll do this [ __ ] yeah really
yeah that's let's wait movie studios
welcome and video switching and all that
stuff yeah we'll be able to do
everything live now dan and we're not so
close the chairs are side by side
yeah I know now I know now we're not
switching flues it's for reals
goddamnit do you like being closer
though I seem like it feels like you
want to be a little closer
well I'm yeah I'm in love with I don't
know if we need to hang this chin it's
kind of good there don't you think I do
a lot more roofie hanging it though I
like it there it looks cool
it's good for my eyes right there me too
okay up we're like this yeah that might
be that feels cozier what do you guys do
for the super well hold on before you
throw Brian chin did you even watch it
yes but I watched it from my own house
by yourself and yeah in your underwear
they're laying down mm-hmm laying down
now would you do bread I was were you
pulling your PUD the whole time I was I
wouldn't I was with frank grillo his
wife your house in my house I called you
invited you
oh that's why you called me yeah and
then I just watched I drank I drank Jose
Cuervo enough immediate reserve enough
emedia tequila I'm a tequila sipper now
oh no you are now is that you you buy a
bottle of that and you can get it you
know for a reasonable price if you try
to buy it per shot in a bar go ahead and
try it's gonna cost you 40 bucks a shot
but you go to a store buy a bottle yeah
yeah but it's delicious
put on some ice and I ate some ate some
very good food and then I just watched
that game and I called it for the Eagles
as it went on because I'm such a problem
so prophetic I just had a feeling they
were gonna win well a lot of people did
man I know it's a matter of fact like
the top betters in the world we're
putting millions of dollars yeah it's
not like though it's not like the yeah
they played well though it was a good it
was very good game man good game pagers
play like themselves to make way too
many mistakes they lost that game nicely
I think they could have actually won a
game they didn't play like themselves
hmm there's no defense which is fun fun
to watch Tom Brady threw for a gut is
that because the defense just toward the
end of the season gets so tired
I don't think so Patriots they were
ranked 28th you know as far as giving up
yardage gonna get in the red zone they
use are pretty good and then I just
think you know the defense wasn't great
what's his name Harrison what's his
first name
I know you tell ya I got from the
Pittsburgh Steelers no yeah but he's now
on ya know he's 39 close to 40 and he's
yeah he's got real legendary work out
yeah she's a little slower for sure yeah
one forty but still it was a good
national geographic is doing this series
on what he does for his body to keep
himself like healthy odds are they go
into the PDS and stuff now oh they don't
Brandon well I don't want to watch that
Brandon I don't see Brandon he does he's
natural well he's clearly 8a just like a
special specimen of a human being right
I mean yeah yeah yeah I mean sure him in
the the same trainer who does Landry
work together that's one adverb and
Brendan are you suggesting now being 40
and Jacqueline is completely normal
well anyways depends who it is some guys
are freaks babies none guys are freaks
um he is a monster a monster what you
think the halftime show Timberlake I
thought it was just okay
I enjoyed that that is not great I
thought it was a disharmony it was - I
couldn't really follow I couldn't hear
his voice you know the you know the Bob
was too much like too much come on I
think the mic was a mind to turn the mic
up loud enough and I thought his dress
was whatever he's wearing his dress
attire was awful do you know why I look
like he raided a blast but he relented
in he didn't stand out cool cos you're
in camel right they date exactly he wore
a Bass Pro Shop shirt and then was like
you know what I mean throw a little
flare in there for my people then he put
on a red frickin bandanna yeah but I
will say about the wardens on he's a
great performer he can dance as well as
any oh he
oh you didn't know he's dancing with
real dancers and he's as good as any of
them even 3070 doing it forever
great voice you got to give it up the
only thing I would say about him is that
I'm like I gotta turn the mic you gotta
turn the mic up and you got to wear an
outfit that separates you so you don't
blend in and it was just too much don't
work in I don't work out my trainer Ben
Bruno how about you flew out there with
him to warm them up before is that right
yeah Wow yeah I didn't I just didn't see
enough I couldn't hear his voice and it
was just too many instruments hjortur
choice on the dress yeah clothing a
terrible choice okay now the quasi the
J's I'm all about the clothing awful
yeah awful yep yes so many is he over
over the they went [ __ ] nuts over the
prints
you know hologram everybody take it easy
I thought it was cool I did too but
people just refer you like what is from
that I know shot a half that Oh sick so
what I know like nothing is sacred stop
acting like this these people I mean
Twitter was a fire it was a storm for
stupid
did you see if people are also upset
well they make fun of them I watched all
the Tom Brady mini docs on Facebook
there's five of them now and Jay and I
watched all of them in Denver and it's
so I mean you become a Tom Brady finding
like my brother hates Tom Brady and we
watch they went you like doing it I'm
kind of rooting for him now I went right
actually not you see his work ethic and
how he flies some teammates to Montana
and they just train non-stop just like a
fun-loving guy see how disciplined he is
where dude it's all football there's a
scene where after he lost that for you
what she brought his loss you know a
bunch of now five won five lost five but
there's a scene where
won five lost five he's been intense
yeah I think so he's been a ton there's
a scene where he's on like he's in
Germany or something with his family and
it's the sons young and he's playing and
he's just like staring off at the sutt
like something and his wife goes what
are you doing and he's like thinking
about the Super Ball cuz he lost it
she's like well does that make you feel
better he's like a little bit like you
just so I think you'd be exhausted
hanging around like those absolute my
arms I one night Michael
you know Kobe Bryant arouse II like you
these absolute winners are exhausting
hanging out well because that all they
care about is winning and losing that
that's literally that's their first love
and on the last one
in his wife who's a supermodel Gisele
who's so hot you don't realize how hot
shoes do you see your walk around the
house you're like oh yeah yeah that's
Tom Brady's girl yeah you best
quarterback of all time
that's his Wilma yeah that's your woman
we have kids they have kids
yeah kids he has sex with her so but you
know that's how hot she is but even she
goes you know his first love is football
like everyone knows that but it's a
little annoying because his dad or he's
just constant and he's sitting there
drinking the shake that he makes every
morning and he's all yeah you know I I
could sit here for seven eight hours and
just watch film it's actually soothing
this what I like to do seven or eight
hours and his kid would whenever he's
with his kid maybe it's just for the
thing is just timing he's kid come in
and he'd put his kid on a slab he's
watching film his dad and he's like tell
him that his dad stories and just like
watch them film everything it's only
football yeah it's only yeah yeah I that
that that one those people are
exhausting yeah they said so there are
stories about Einstein who would wear
the same outfit every day so we didn't
have to think about anything else I
don't know if that's true but that was
the myth where he would where he would
have his he basically wear the same
clothing so he didn't have to think
about what he was gonna wear that day no
one put energy like that just one thing
one thing one thing you know that Dad
that obsession that that decision to
just drill into and Tom Tom Brady's
forty you know and he's working with Tom
House who I've met a bunch of times
through Tebow and Tim would work with
him I'd go out there and train with
those guys and Tom goes age is just it's
just a number it's just in your head and
time does the alligator [ __ ] about that
and it throws like the perfect ball
because only [ __ ] about that just you
sees like a regular dudes deer and then
they're with his crew like Edelman and a
medulla and he flies them to Montana
where they can just focus on football
and this is the offseason so he flies
and they're still being worked on routes
and stuff and they're roasting Edelman
so hard because he was in the weight
room
badge an element like it makes me feel
better like I like do as me that stuffs
and times like that does nothing for you
for our sport that you're wasting your
time they're just like roasting him an
element like [ __ ] off man
he's like for me it makes you feel good
and Tom Brady's like you know what makes
you feel good and he's getting massaged
cesium rub down he goes this puts up a
nice throwing arm and flexes on him he
just seems like a regular dude but as
far as a dad and then Brady was getting
roasted because he's getting rubbed down
this he's always constant work on his
body he's getting because he's 40 and
he's getting rubbed down and his kid
comes and goes dad I want to do this
this and this and Tom goes what do I get
the kid gives a little peck on the lips
I kiss my son non-stop on lips Sarah and
he goes that's it and the kid comes back
and they like they hold the kiss for
like 10 seconds
just little Epping is much better and
everyone's just roasting breaking and
I'm like that's people without kids
don't say that yeah you live in this
weird culture where you like like I
posted did you see the my favorite Super
Bowl commercial I post on Instagram you
probably haven't seen it with a Eli
Manning and a Beckham jr. bring it up
you're gonna love this but I post it was
my favorite one to the you know it's
these guys get in a comfort zone and
being silly geese and you look at the
Comets and I wonder what's wrong with
society I think their own insecurities
we people put like all these guys are
gay or [ __ ] I'm like yeah no no no that
it's awesome and like joking around
it's just calm it's just weird like
meathead culture where I'm like oh god
if someone's in two fashions exact so in
our society right now maybe has always
been very very weird and puritanical I
mean we don't even know how to deal with
it we nobody really wants to talk about
the truth behind erotic like the truths
behind errata sysm and sexual like the
sexual truth of who we really are which
is we are [ __ ] in a lot of ways
monkeys and hyper sexual see the fifty
billion dollar porn industry I get that
but I see what is it with the brycie
where you go on saying what is it with
guys who probably in their mom's
basement probably don't have a
girlfriend or maybe they do we're
anything that you know like if I post
something fashion they go oh oh that's
gay or oh you're that you you buy
suck dick or or it's like with with
Beckham jr. and these guys having fun
it's like oh my god these guys are gay I
think I think that cause I think it
comes from also like I want to kill
their tari they're been through make
sure they're like open some theories
written about this and one of the one of
the theories that I have read from
anthropologists is the idea that first
of all in hunter-gatherer societies it
was a lot of times it wasn't really you
know they had very different ideas of
sexual norms but like when you have a
display of what would be considered
homoerotic ISM you know what by the way
was accepted in Greek culture but if you
have one in like a our culture there's
this idea to describe homo Rus ism so
that social kissing two men holding
hands two men you know whatever it might
be that was considered a threat to the
status quo right the idea that that we
are we are only a species as long as we
can breed and yes that's why children
will be protected and everything else
and when you don't have that when you
have two men doing that it is an affront
to the norms that have established what
what monogamy is what we educated don't
act like that most people who have
evolved and who are educated in or
around you know decent friends don't act
like that like you would never post if I
posted a picture of me and chin dancing
you would never put on the go goddamn
you guys are gay no I would never but
but but that's probably also because I
have been exposed to a lot of gay people
and this is gonna sound crazy but when
you're exposed to a lot of gay people
there they're just like people yeah I
mean but it's not even that because that
see I don't that won't even crossed my
mind if I see Odell dancing with him I
find it funny it doesn't cross my mind
that is homoerotic
well yeah but part of the idea would be
that yeah I mean part of the idea is
that you got AI Manning throwing his
head and doing these sort of what would
be traditionally considered feminine
movements and so now I get it you're
hilarious
yeah um of a man married with three kids
people just find it threatening man if I
wonder what that is yet I ask yourself
what - are you surround you
you get a lot of cultures you get beaten
up or killed for it but not our culture
but I get that people go caveman would
which do on 18 you can't meet like you
keep me can't leave a like came in those
[ __ ] left her there about 28
years old if you had a cold you died
we're past that
yeah so now we're in this educated
society and maybe you work at Amazon you
work in an office and you're a bro
checked out it's so [ __ ] gay yeah it
doesn't make sense to me anymore well
it's so it's strange to bigotry and I
think it's more of them it's it's them
laughs now make sure I'm not gay
everyone look at it so that I'm gonna
hate on this this guy's get this guy's
gay right you're not a really
interesting psycho a psychological
phenomenon so that my family brother is
it yeah it is so they found there's an
interesting theory behind this they
found that men who who kill gay men like
you know as those those the guys who get
into groups and they they would call
this called gay bashing that used to be
a thing a lot of those guys are doing it
because they're terrified that they have
some gay in them and they're trying to
kill that that sort of makes more sense
yeah that that that impulse in
themselves and that has that has been
that has at least been studied
psychologic don't know a lot of guys
realize like let's say you have a girl
you're trying to pursue a girl you
realize even they're like good god man
what are you doing it what kind of loser
would post that on a on a thing a meme
or something like it's a it's a way of
feeling better than the other person in
a way of exerting your power over to
over Beckham and Manning well look gay
gay like so so you you first of all
you're identifying with a group of other
people that are anti-gay or at least you
know men it kind of no way to assert you
I don't think they're anti-gay you think
they don't I've been when I'm well I
mean when I mean guys are posted I grew
up in locker rooms yeah you know where
we grab each other's ass something like
that or just mess around a lot of gay
joke around with straight guys isn't
there was it Hans but they're not
actually like I remember if there was
suspicion or guy was gay no one was mean
to him hurt their feelings no one no
one's actually homophobic right you mean
you made a lot of jokes right yeah yeah
in other words I remember when it was a
friend of ours who came out and he
didn't wanna come out for a long time
because he thought we'd made fun of him
we were all like dude
we're all pros you know we're all pros
here but we're not gonna make funny
thank you clearly fact if you came out
and said hey guys guess what I [ __ ] guys
like my buddy Keith this is really macho
he goes like this he goes
here's there's a million you guys I suck
[ __ ] and there is a hat we all lose
because he doesn't give a [ __ ] you know
but but nor what I cares all he's not
hurting anyone
yeah like if someone came out was like
yeah man I touch kids I'm like well I'm
gonna not only beat you up and I'm have
to report your authorities even if even
if is you got to remember that I'm
different when you went but remember
this is a very good point because when
people traditionally said they were gay
do we get okay why they were they were
going against quote-unquote God's laws
they were they were a moral and they
were lending that and and and it still
painted this way in some circles they
were sort of lending themselves to the
eventual decay of society so if we allow
this the homage if we allow this is an
affront to marriage as it stands right
so if you allow gay marriage then what
about regular marriage no you know but
again think how stupid you have to be to
be part of KKK in this day and age and
think that you know black people are in
fury or or gazing whatever stupid you
remember what KKK what the KK care now
doing like so even racists like guys
like that go I'm not racist I'm just Pro
white and that's how they're framing it
like this guy was like I'm just Pro
white I'm anti leftist liberals I just
think that you know we we have a right
to be celebrating my white culture
whatever that is and any because I could
[ __ ] such an umbrella and he goes and
and he goes I said hey I was like this
guy's in he had like he looked like a
kind of a hipster and he goes and we
should kill all the Jews and I was like
well I'm actually amazing that
commercial cheers it's the best
commercial on the thing you'll love this
be oh I saw it it's funny as [ __ ]
good turn good turn Manning so stiff yes
yes and that I guarantee they took a
week to stay that leave oh [ __ ]
now Beckham is not stiff any can dress
is a saw Beckham it's a beautiful man
right
it's also the best receiver in the NFL
how stiff is just let him dance I think
this is funny shit's hilarious but he
likes just so T so bad at it I wonder if
they really did this cuz that's not easy
to do
no I think he's on strength you think so
yeah well you and I tried that and stuff
for me [ __ ] yeah well that's super tough
yeah except that you're gonna throw out
my face haha how'd the time of when I
would kill that yeah yeah we went you
don't have to run at me don't look at me
soft like that bro I'm just saying we do
well I don't know did you swallowing
hard right now don't take big sips out
of straw how we do with and have a wet
mouth our babies we do great I want you
to catch me man oh dude you're kind of
big and strong you would flows long
issues are just terrible you don't know
[ __ ] what are those bro when eyes are
jordan v bella edition very hard to get
are they hard to get to you are they
that's great you're the pink and the
purple with bel-air Fresh Prince of
bel-air man oh give up [ __ ] bro you
don't know now we're in the same great
outfit oh there's business socks oh
there yeah but these are my sunglasses
right are you Einstein you put no effort
no life do you like to wear something
every day I don't know if an indoor
soccer master can break out I want to be
ready [ __ ] - Cudi Bryan great
shoes by the tamarillo last night giving
me a boxing lesson and and without
gloves actually hitting me in the
stomach and I'm like you you're hitting
me in the face
Franklin was too a girl for me oh my god
like to relax yeah well Franco going box
for an hour and a half when he's in a
city home he just he crashes gyms on a
percent alright gents we have some
current events
sure the first one is today it's
apparently a really big day for people
to call in sick the day after the Super
Ball so according to a survey 14 million
people are calling in sick today 14
million plus one cuz MJ's the same 50 oh
yeah they're 14 million plus one it's
people who drink a lot
drank a little last night I got a little
buzzed I never do
did you uh slept [ __ ] slept hard
because I had to wake up early now you
have to do that we got two shows maybe
you work out and that that's Saturday
and then you go to bed at o1 and you're
up at 3 your time early on that plane
yeah it's fun to sleep in those planes
those seats are super comfortable and
then you're just getting asleep and I
just slept I had last night or during
the Superbowl no last night I had dreams
a gang can kick again kick again I don't
know what that means I felt intense - I
was so tired I fell asleep during the
Super Ball oh yeah third core I missed
the entire third quarter I woke up
during the fourth Wow
that was really exciting I did some
Jesus sorry I grew I filled my infamous
big brown burgers which you haven't had
yet some say it's the best well you
don't invite your some dates the best in
LA is a grass-fed you never invite me
over
I don't bite anyone over man I never go
out huh then we go in here yeah dude we
got to do uh dinner for your birthday
yes Thursday or Friday you Pig I'll take
you done Thursday I'm in Brea
I'm Embraer this Thursday this Friday
and this Saturday maybe Wednesday it's
gonna be tough
yeah there's your Friday said um come
see me and Brad by the way Thursday
Friday Saturday are you anywhere no I
start shooting my show this month
oh well you don't say no right to
Arizona for Valentine's Day are you
anywhere there I'm at the Tempe improv
than I meant Phoenix live hey some guy
came my show him and his gorgeous wife
and I made fun of your teeth during my
set and it's a new bit I do about you
get metal braces anyways this guy came
up with metal braces
handsome man and goes dude tell Kalin
and he goes Invisalign doesn't work when
you're over 30 really it really goes
yeah it kind of straighten them but
doesn't work he goes I've been doing it
on and off for four years as I went to
the dentist and she does want to be
honest I think as gay goes in order for
you at your age your teeth fix and he
said his bottom teeth are like yours
looks like a city skyline and his were
yellow yeah he said he's bored the metal
ones for six months and they're all
perfectly straight I should like I can't
shoot with braces you know what they can
do it on the inside problem is I don't
worry I got a we're right I can't show
and two of them happens I can't have any
on the inside because I I've already
looked into it I can't chew my teeth I
have a weird bite where if I have got
under my side I like wag my er I just
got I got a high palate I have it's it's
when people are very charismatic they
have arts feats and high palates flat so
it worked for you while it for me why
they yell oh no no my teeth are not
yellow that's that's not true that is
because I have it all you guys didn't
see Brian's bottom teeth I swear to God
or like nah that's not true literally
like don't do that with your fingers it
looks like you ever see your receipt oh
hey my bad man return now he has the
teeth like Danny DeVito Spencer now it
looks like this no no sir that's not
that's not don't do their teeth don't
like they are fighting for my time
that's deep why won't you buy invisible
like that then get your bottom teeth out
for me they like a bulldog
[Laughter]
some guy was defend the metal braces
though I just wish you'd embrace it bro
my my [ __ ] nose is more bulbous I've
noticed lately it's gonna thick yeah I
get too thick on the end I don't like
only who knows your ears are oh you're
the old man here you know why cuz all
your ears and nose grow yeah I know man
I like your earlobes I'm getting you
can't reduce your ears and you can't
reduce your nose my that's the two
things that grow I know and maybe
there's a way to reduce my nose size you
get a nose job I'd be a bummer yeah
there's so many things nothing's funny
about a nose job I told you that that I
wake up in the morning I'm like all
puffy and I'm on the Goldbergs and I go
I face is always puffy in the morning I
can't figure it out and these veteran
veteran makeup bars go are you uh
drinking at night and I go every night
they know they're like don't do that
yes all on drinking yeah don't evil
shitload don't need a wheel of cheese
and drink six box wine [ __ ] I took
your picture at the airport with these
uh I think they're they were coming from
a fight out of his you see or what and
it's 4:00 in the morning up there poor
there you get a picture on it sure man
it's more and more of my face is super
swollen he goes who it is swollen
yeah well take the picture and I look
like a giant budda mom oh yeah in the
morning just my face swells up well I
use like I did eat when a wheel of
cheese I had a shitload of barbeque in
pizza so that's what happens when I was
in Italy I decided to eat I'm not
kidding I was eating a wheel of cheese a
day and I was drinking as much one as
possible
and waking up in the middle of might'n
doing it I wouldn't have to do though
you got to do it and I was waking up
with my girlfriend the time it became my
wife she was like dude you are you're so
ugly you have to stop this my sister
goes you need somebody to stick a needle
in your face and drain them yeah I shoot
my sister was like the kids are not
recognized you need caring did your did
your hands and feet swell up here had
that all I'll know if I'm eating bad too
if my feet swell up cuz I'll go to put a
switch five like one of my boots on oh
my foot won't fit in the up so on the
plane that's gotta be healthy
oh gallon that's uric acid no I'm good
my buddy Jerry gets uric he gets a gout
which is a build above
uric acid that's not when you eat half a
cow and you drink six gallons of [ __ ]
red wine every night I told you I got a
stage 1 pre-diabetes huh yeah you want
blood were you at stage 1 so that means
type 1 diabetes stage 1 they call it
stage 1 pre-diabetes but you eat so well
so it makes no sense well she said as
long as you keep you you know you she
was you're typically on a good diet and
you worked out so it should be fine but
she said with your work and your stress
it could be you know it's onset
pre-diabetes of stage 1
but she said because my father has it my
grandpa had it and so my uncles have it
genetic yeah but shows all you take care
of yourself should be alright every
genetic you're knocking yeah of AIDS
anyways the next one is a girl that's on
The Bachelor she was actually reported
missing I remember her she was beautiful
Rebecca yes she was beautiful she was
young her mom reported her missing in
November and I guess she said that she
was gonna call her mom like in a week
she's gonna work on a marijuana farm the
mom didn't here for like a week so she
called the police she was on a
missing-persons database and then a week
later the sheriff's actually called said
did you find your daughter yet and she
was yeah we found her she seems like
she's okay now
but the sheriff's couldn't get in touch
with her the daughter cuz she's on a TV
show there's no phone calls
oh oh maybe she because when you are on
I know people have been on the shows
you're not allowed to talk to anybody no
cell phones yeah so she was on there for
two months and a viewer found her on the
show and reported it and finally they
were able to take her off the database
but she was still on the database while
she was on the show I don't get cell
service at uh layers and she's gorgeous
by the way she looks
she's yes I love short hair I don't
think she won but she was she looks like
Tinkerbell for there's a real one real
life short hair that's by far the it's
by far the worst bachelor season one
time it's so boring don't why I quit
watch it i watch the beginning where
they picked the girls mmm because I
loved seeing all the crazy [ __ ] and then
I don't watch it but this woman who had
our baby cut out of her stalked
what oh yeah thirty-eight-year-old lures
the 22 year old in the same
armen complex and she and her boyfriend
and she gave the woman a cesarean baby
was perfectly fine and took the baby out
of her body did the lady die
she sure did oh man she sure did people
are so why would you breathe in your
brother that is happening how's that
[ __ ] that hard to do that's right
there gruesome details no I know I don't
need that mother you didn't read that
[ __ ] we keep going with us yes that
girl's father not Thurman let the one on
bachelor did you see Kevin Hart at the
soup I haven't seen it he's been getting
roasted though yeah did you see him try
and cover up with ice
Oh check out my friend who's just wasted
I am ha let me see what happens here
well so this is just one part of it
during the NFL broadcast he's talking
you tell his buzz super buzz super and
right here the D odd yeah
so he said that for it on my blog yeah I
just hammered amazing drunk man what
sister watch his rebuttal let's crack
let me see where he's uh where he tries
to rush the stage you know when did the
stage so you can see him here ain't
happy yeah an art like he's like ain't
happenin
damn he was chocolate wasted he's white
girl wasted and then this is Kevin's
mister afterwards actually the spoiler
is actually my mouth oh well he's here
know when alcohol is in your system you
do dumb stuff me trying to go on stage
with the trophy definitely a matte top
two stupid things this president cares
the Eagles won a Super Bowl
yeah I'm still a little tipsy the world
can kiss my ass shut up [ __ ] I ain't
got to [ __ ] some food cuz I'm tipsy my
wife was the first one to say babe don't
go up there I told my wife beat now
honey chill out I got to be up there
with my city I went to walk he put his
hand on my chest
who gives a [ __ ] go Eagles fly Eagle fly
[ __ ] is he owns it I like that industry
and the hashtags are funny like hash tag
he said he was dehydrated hashtag he
sucked the bottle has the bottle as if
it's his last he's so stupid
let's take his jersey [ __ ] he's so fine
I like it because I I think you know
someone on his level of celebrity you
know they they're they're just people
they're just people
he's from failures a big deal form so
you had a bunch of drinks and then go
and do something like this fun yeah I
mean
shirt sober up and don't go on NFL
Network and stuff like that but he's so
far I think it's fun man he's such a
good person yeah I know I love giving
her back I think it's good for being
that he's just regular like everybody
oldest what else you got Jen all right
this is he I'm not sure where this is
but it's in China and it's a bad one but
it's a boar attacking an older man why a
wild boar in China and then the I'll
just play the video
don't be older like so check this why is
he killing them he just ran and we came
out of that little forest area so this
is his daughter-in-law trying to save
him as well and then he just goes oh it
starts attacking her right now - damn
[ __ ] 220 pound beast was he trying to
eat the dren attacker all seriousness
what do you do here Oh shot by snipers
yes oh this is a crazy wild war on the
ground man dude that boar
yes sadly the man oh yeah but the lady
did it no serious injuries the holy [ __ ]
what did it do bite him and stuff and no
horns son got a damaged run - oh god
damn what a terrible way to go man 66
years old
what's wrong with that boy did you get
on top of it and choke it out I don't
think so you have to bro skins are so
thick in that situation you got to get
on the back I got an idea I'm we going
front like it just calm down
then you're gonna crawl up like that
high in him bite his nuts well you got
to fight it off if he's attacking you'll
know look you're behind this is that big
old pours nuts yeah like this ah and
then he dies like the water buffalo it's
our only hope you're jagged sharp teeth
get right underneath and rip his nuts
off I don't I don't want to cuz then
he's gonna oh my god and they're just us
then it took a sniper to kill you
hundred twenty pounds you're bigger than
that so you have to it's on you to fight
that [ __ ] thing well I'm real he's
taller 20 pounds I'm not 240 that's hog
strength that's hog muscle he went down
to the village because of snow in the
mountains
I bombs to find figured I'd that sucks
damn
I've never seen an actual bore attack
that was the first time I actually saw a
bore attack you ever talk to our ground
nasty that's why you had dogs hold him
at bay when you come in there and kill
them with a knife
no I'm all about people to kill them oh
yeah oh yeah and that was intense
did you see on the side there says seems
to gall accused of sexual assault no
[ __ ] oh yeah I think you wear a man
button yo classes and you already not
know he had to read a rape like ring
they say he's been yes he's got ah he's
bi let's just say I did a movie with his
ex-wife and Kelly brought LeBron and I
never heard I didn't hear anything but
well it doesn't tell them because that
penthouse I read an article a long time
ago on him pan House Road this is way
before anything I'm glad you ex wife and
penthouse well the well is given me it
was like read this because if it's pan
houses writing about it was like
probably might even player a playboy
Penthouse but it was like it was a crazy
article about both don't you know really
he's always had a reputation I thought
that I'm not defending the women I've
done movies with him and said bad things
I heard in Louisiana he's part of that
sex remember bring that came out and he
had a lot of trouble for that
really yeah you'd like this weird like
sex ring he's got some he's got some
like section so I think he's probably
he's bad guys I mean if that's gonna by
the FBI tell you right now come here
whoops everybody's ass I've seen the
videos lately in Russian I have I have
indeed be careful of that guy under
siege 3 what else you get gen Logan Paul
it just turns out he's tried to go
skydiving and one of his parachutes
actually didn't open [ __ ]
publicity start he's gonna put on a vlog
so people tried to him trying to get the
public back on his side I almost died
everybody feel sorry for me in a trip
you know I guess parachute didn't open I
don't know if it's trip yeah this kids
uh yeah I'm after I'm after I've never
been on the train I'm definitely off it
now
I think whatever he does just it's all
fake yeah I think it's obviously hits
and trying to distract from his horrible
thing who's that oh that's that dude
from Glee
okay maybe it was the ID that that's a
terrible what had anything to like he
was connected to child porn and oh
that's why I killed him so yeah dude so
what happened he was connected to all
these different child porn cases and I
guess he had to face them in court and
give his money and all that stuff even
in the future he just killed himself
before doing any of that stuff
yeah however he did have money left over
that he gave to the families I guess
after he died oh but his that his stuff
is crazy like really really young kids
and he was palpable in it like he was he
was well he will download all sorts of
porn with kids that are super young I
heard like really really young evil evil
yeah I think he just has sickness so he
killed himself he was a celebrity
Hussein he was a huge celebrity on Glee
- yeah please
well I member it's really sad we're like
oh no and then now you find out that
you're like oh yeah it's like oh thank
you okay thanks for doing us a favor
yeah well what out yeah I mean did you
see the video I posted that dad in court
was a $3 bill yes I did yes needs a
movement coach let's be honest well on
the coach and you also don't warn people
you got about to say that he goes I was
about to say that
play the video chance because what I'm
doing is this I'm going I'm going good I
I get my fur and then just jump and grab
that dude and buy these [ __ ] nose off
this I do like because I think he was
doing this honestly for his daughter I
think it was more theatrical to show his
daughter how much I don't know I think
he's really upset of course he was I
don't think he thought of course he was
but I think he was saying if he needs if
not he knows he's not gonna alternate
opposing coach yeah five minutes would
you give me one minute
who's laughing Wow see the only reason
why I buy it is because as he's moving
as well I'm gonna have to well I think
he yeah I would he came out of nowhere
I've been like yeah I got that man as
soon as as soon as they distract that
mouse yeah I got to get my hands I just
wanted my hands on his ears but pulling
his ears off yeah but the thing is they
have all those officers around cuz they
know it was flat him the people are
trying to get to him so it's gonna be
tough that's why you gotta be real you
got to be like you know what I forgive
you I just want you to know that night
yeah like that like you know what I just
want she I just want she said I want you
to know I respect
can I just shakes in because I'm gonna
get over it and how about the guy who
drank poison that dude who that Serbian
guy who was on they were or was he
Croatian where the Hague in The Hague in
the trip the World Court the tribunal
Court and he was being tried as a war
crime as a general and he said I'm
innocent and this is a travesty of
justice and he drank [ __ ] poison he
made a speech right there right in front
of me buddy this was four months ago
there's been a shocking protest at a war
crimes tribunal in the Netherlands
that's him that's him
of Croatian forces during the Bosnian
war told the court he'd swallowed poison
the judge had just upheld his sentence
of 20 years why the wise the judge looks
like he's on twitch or something he just
killed himself why he died right there
I'd like judge we're in a Bluetooth to
hear piece and playing video games look
at that afterwards Loren Camuto has
covered the international trash right
like that boom his head he was shaking
his so scared he was like well he was
good guy I don't know I don't know
enough about the thing but he was a see
that that war was uh was essentially
what it was uh oh my God look at that
freak don't go that far wrist m8 so the
fart loaded down no no
down that let me see that was one of
those guys who was up general and you
know this was I've taken poison I have
taken the ref co-star the judge goes
what up I'm playing why don't they'll
win that Bulls he just he just collapsed
and didn't work that fast
oh yeah cyanide he's a very he's a
general he's a he's a water potato nose
yeah he's a big dude I'm not a criminal
the guy's been through some [ __ ] yeah
this war was a terrible war between the
Krotz and the certainly did did the guy
did the guy actually kill people though
yeah there was a lot of awful killing
out of all sides and so now they're
which is or crimes tribunal basically
try war criminals people see his hands
shaking because it's like you're going
yeah but he stood up and said I'm not a
criminal I'd rather die than be treated
this way Jesus died dad for what he
believed was his Hosanna ain't nobody
want that down no it was mansion yeah
let's see oh the Spice Girls are you
faded this at all and are a fan I'm a
fan of Mel I'm afraid okay how's the
other ones though I've met I spent
mazzaglia Emma an event I'm there to
bond um they look good yo who's the one
the top left sporty spice they have
support our series your spice crew ah I
still think males number one but sporty
spice is not challenging all that Jesus
man there look it looks like they're
gonna reunite for something tell me what
you want what you really really well
I'll tell you what I want what I
well I wanna I wanna I wanna oh if there
are times when I was in England and I
was with scary spy sure have know
several times and and I said why why is
she why are we be driven around who's
who's who's chauffeured driven limo
whose painful yeah well that's Emma
she's Baby Spice I was like Oh big deal
okay didn't know that how they were so
big there's really no big is there
there's really no big female bands now
yeah only fifth harmony right actual
group ooh they have some jizz eoms - I'm
not mad at anything I tell you I was
walking with Mel through a party and the
guy goes I'll tickle your belly button
from the inside I've never forgotten
that because he's right there and he was
a very macho breath I was like I'm gonna
call it right now I gotta just listen
you should have defended her honor and
seeing if any poets young enough and
solid enough - I was young I was do
enough that I would have I would have
absolutely they should have for her for
her I would have I would have done
something and then I would have gotten
stomped she came in there like that dad
in that courtroom let me on the bathroom
okay no no you're not going to bath
until we're done that it change me a
more oh crap I do think I have no not
this someone said is this is this Bryan
Callen yeah like later cuz he has the
same dance moves
no he see him later in life force acting
100% it's just you and him dude it's
very similar be rate that shirt in the
chain are awful is the Under Armour
shirt on he's quitting true religion
jeans there's nothing worse than seeing
a man
that's a joke I hope that's you guys
look very similar that's you in 20 years
bro no you don't have a great beard and
you're here it's not that fun god damn
that's so depressing oh you see an old
person dressed like a young though not
the worst so works s you fee
that's enough as they say you know I
started watching cuz I've Peter like
don'ts the greatest comedy variety show
of all time letting the lady in the show
I've started season 3 I know our boy
Piven pops up with zero here that's
right oh they go gently get vivid yeah
he got the old he got the old operation
great job though he popped them away oh
my god let it sit up yeah and then short
laugh that he's cast as George Costanza
stubble in Seinfeld you know that I did
not know that's fast now but the
adulation show brilliant Oh great show
great show man Wow
I love that show you know Jon Stewart
was a writer on there in Judd Apatow
that's the writers room yeah Jon Stewart
Jon that was Garry Shandling who could
pick talent when you hear people talk
about Garry Shandling they've got so
much respect for you know what to it I
was at uh who's this is years ago I was
that uh he was on Saturday live big guy
Hans and Franz Kevin I was at Kevin
Nealon 50th birthday party and Garry
Shandling 60 and at 60th and at the time
he was like shaking he's out of it
I really didn't you know everyone's like
that scares you and he's brilliant like
really you know I didn't know too much
about him that he obviously passed away
but you look at the stuff he did
something happened something happened
after the Larry Sanders show something I
don't know what it was but he just
stopped producing as much he stopped
doing anything it seems he was brilliant
huh yeah really
comedy mind what he did like that said
that I totally that story about Jeffrey
Tambor called him up well yeah because
Jeffrey Tim on his show my hey now we
have an activator Jeffrey and I shared
the same acne treatment Oh Jeffrey was
my I was gonna say Jeffrey was your
acting - yes but I we shared another an
acting term emkin solace and Milton and
he said I don't know what to do I had
this great audition and Milton said call
him they said call him and he goes yeah
you guys it's between you and some
people call him it was between him and
two other people so Jeffrey called up
Garry Shandling goes look
do this never done this in my life and
working forever Geoffrey's never stopped
working right he's an amazing actor and
he goes I just I just feel like this is
my part this is an amazing thing and I
would never usually do this I don't do
this and Gary there was a pause and Gary
said you may not but the character would
and he got the part
damn yeah that's so cool then that's so
guys you may not but the character would
that's so fast for a ssin how about the
Garry Shandling and Jerry Seinfeld were
talking and Jerry goes I don't get this
come in he sees I kind of frustrates
like people say comics have come from
this rough upbringing there's dark past
and all that stuff because I don't get
why people do that you don't have to be
dark to be a great comedian Garry
Shandling goes why so angry Jerry it
just leaves it at that he's like huh
why so angry yeah he's like yeah he was
a very very smart people is it afraid
some people it's really interesting like
there are certain authors that'll write
two books or the certain musicians it'll
right - amazing albums and then that's
it in some ways in some ways like that's
all they were meant to do Bob Dylan they
were talking on one of the giants one of
the poetic Giants in rock and roller or
folk music whatever you want to call it
and they were they were talking about
his he was older and he was very wealthy
and they were talking about the songs he
wrote and he said ain't that something
and they said what do you mean he said
it's just I don't know who wrote those
there's a you never do that again
never but I was so desperate to be heard
or whatever you do you ever not that one
comparing us to any of those gentlemen
but do you ever think back on your sets
and stuff and even your setting out yeah
how the [ __ ] did I come up with that
there's no way I'm gonna do that again
all the time I'll see em on the plane
ride from st. Louis I'm like what am I
gonna do what the hell am I gonna face
that every time so I was like after I'm
done with this what am I gonna do I'm
gonna shoot my thumb ready I'm ready to
shoot my third special and then I have
to throw it all away and start again I
have no idea I haven't by the way I had
no idea how I came up with this stuff
like now they're fully formed bits yeah
I'm doing I'm and it's working so well
like who came up with that notice I
don't really know but I remember doing
either on how it's all it's all become
thematic I have no idea strange yeah I
was going on my step you tiles go over
my sister
I'm the plane riding like where the [ __ ]
did I come up with over talks about that
would help me like to what where what
was I do like and well that I would
never I did a little burn I did a show
bill burr at the ice house and he said
this ending is I hate this part of the
time and I go why he goes just shot my
special I'm trying new stuff it's just
the worst I was like yep
nobody is funny if stand-up is one of
the things that nobody just can just do
you got to work at it carve [ __ ] find
bits find it you know you're writing a
song but that's what I love about it cuz
it's a constant process of discovery I
know I mean is when you look back I like
what oh I know I know and that's what I
love about it you just keep coming back
to the well so keep coming back keep
coming back and it'll it's almost like
it slowly reveals itself sometimes it
shows itself and it's full things
sometimes it doesn't like I woke up from
a dream when I was thinking about an
ostrich and I was like that thing's a
kung-fu turkey turkey and that was like
that's the joke nobody I go you know a
350 pound kung-fu Turkey that's not
really for and it was it was one of my
best bits yet first strains okay it'll
come to you if you just keep thinking I
just keep thinking back but that's what
no you can do it like you can obsess it
you can actually in a way like what you
get more energy as you think about those
things some days I'll just be writing
all day yeah but then if it's very
strange because if you're like right
today I'm gonna write for six hours
don't work like that now it's not gonna
come to you like you might have bits and
points that you can work on but I like
it comes out weird time so so so a lot
of times for me I'll say I got to write
six hours and I and the whole day is
prot a process procrastination cut my
hair or walk around go have some coffee
I gotta take a [ __ ] I got to go work out
I got I got a stretch now and I can't
write I can't write and then like six
seventh hour you'll be role usual I saw
something get into the thing and then I
have to do my shuffle airs yeah it's a
process of frustration I though it's
funny but when that when you're saying
that remember when Bob Dylan Lee I don't
know who wrote that yeah I think about
myself playing like I don't know how I
could what am I gonna do after this yeah
what's a Springsteen concert one time
and when he started singing his new
songs you could see and I'm and it was
like a river of people leaving to go to
the bathroom and get drinks like River
he said he talked about it he goes dude
I started singing a new song and
everybody would leave to get that with
Chris Rock also talks about like the
company's different now because you know
if you're a big name in comedy or people
pay to see you and you're trying new
bits like geysers they don't have the
same kind of balls for lack of better
term that the old comics outcomes go up
there and do that you know try their new
stuff and now it's like great the common
strain you try new stuff and you bomb
it's tough because you got brogue in
there you got Brian you got D'Elia so
pick you up they're trying stuff it's
like you're and you're in a killers role
killer because everybody's destroying
the room and you know it's hot dove was
dove was like at his dove we had
co-headlined helium Noah hilarities in
Cleveland and it was New Year's and dub
was doing [ __ ] like he had his old stuff
cuz he was about to shoot a special I
was tryin all new [ __ ] he would destroy
it I would just eat a dick I need a bag
of dicks man and they're right and I
hear them go you were so much better
than the other
like I just hear I didn't care because I
was like I know that's the word the
stage I'm at but they were such [ __ ]
they're like bro you or you or you or
better you should have been why they had
the other guy oh [ __ ] man but sometimes
yeah people come to like dude your bread
this guy like when did you see him he
went yeah well and you I if so if I know
I'm like well I know where they're at
you're definitely off on that they're
probably trying some news well somebody
said that to me somebody said something
I don't know if it's true and but I was
doing a benefit and Adam Sandler was
there and I guess somebody said that
Adam found out that he was gonna follow
me and I don't said I'd rather not a
rather go before him and so I was like
yeah man I go that's not because Adam
Sandler is less funny it's because he
hasn't doing stand-up and he probably
doesn't feel like doing something with a
guy who's been doing it constantly and
wet you can't yeah that means nothing it
means it's just and I don't know it's
true that's what I was told it's just
like anybody would be in that situation
doing stand-up you don't wanna follow
somebody's gonna do their best [ __ ]
stuff how about engine app tells book
they were doing a tribute to uh I forget
who it was some big-time comic huge
comic and sir Silverman went up and I
can got him Sandler went up and he goes
in there just crushing and he uses his
wife
brings his wife with him and she says
like positive things and gets him the
right frame of mind but he brought his
daughter and he was about to go on stage
and that was on TV and he said Silverman
went up before him and had kind of the
same premises and just rushed and he
looked at his daughter when I'm scared
it's like daddy don't grow up now I'm
scared too
and he's like [ __ ] this and they go
judge you up me knows I'm not going out
there and didn't know oh my god didn't
go good yeah who is it who is it was
talking about doing stand-up for Robert
De Niro I mean it was like it was like
literally James Cameron it was like and
and like the president it was like it
was a sit-down thing and he had to get
up so there's no stage he got up in
among the tables and was doing stand-up
and going around it might have been
Jamie Foxx and it did not go well it did
not like he got a big guy so genero it's
like look at this guy the way he's
dressing tener wasn't laughing it was
like and apparently I think it was Jamie
was somebody but it was bad it was like
there's nothing worse than that no I
will never put myself in that position
when people ask me to do those big
benefits like that I'm like who's there
because I had to do something where all
these big people with their huge
producers of other tim tebow finishes no
that was terrible there's another one I
got away with it I pulled it off somehow
but because I I was so nervous I go I
had my material and I started writing I
had to rewrite [ __ ] like right there and
I pulled it off by the compliment of my
teeth and then they asked me to come and
do something in New York for 1,100
people and I crashed and burned so hard
this is now when I got like I'm pretty
[ __ ] up but you know crash so we do
those blah stakes our way all three
people will end up liking everybody else
I've had some bad experiences with those
things corporate gigs are always iffy
well I'll tell you I can have a bad
experience in bryan callen Braille this
weekend's write a Friday Saturday that's
right who shows you tonight that's right
but Thursday Friday Saturday very improv
Bryan Callen the kid himself I'm there
Thursday Friday Saturday next thing for
me I will be Vancouver March 1st at sold
out and a March though
tickets for Orlando just went on sale so
it's thanks to 23rd 24th 25th
goes Tampa Palm Beach Orlando those
tickets just went on sale get them right
now oh [ __ ] what am I talking about then
- this month February I'm in the comedy
store La Jolla Comedy Store Thursday
Friday come store La Jolla that's not
what's next County store La Jolla get it
brides and Brad this weekend though yes
sir get after that I mean call it
I mean Arizona Tempe improvin in Phoenix
live sir come see me both Valentine's
Day Tempe improv Oh Abbi your wife like
that oh yeah
she'll have fun I don't believe in
Valentine's Day not buying her it's a
maid it's a made up all [ __ ] holiday
[ __ ] off yes I agree with that
all right guys from the new studio this
is the fired kid we're out